welcome back to CBS this morning
Saturday while much of the country has
sunny weather this time of year San
Francisco is an exception the city is
frequently shrouded in fog for much of
the season and recently that weather
phenomena not only acquired a name but a
social-media account and thousands of
followers
John Black's don't have that story in
San Francisco it's a typical summer day
the fog is in high points on buildings
and bridges may poke into the Sun but
much of the city is engulfed in grey
yeah the cool water for meteorologist
Mike Peck 'nor who is somewhere there in
the fog this is exactly the way it's
supposed to be we're coming along here
there's nothing but a wall of white out
there for summertime in San Francisco
that's what you're gonna see is a wall
of white fog is the natural
air-conditioning of San Francisco funky
but it presents a challenge for tourists
searching for that perfect picture of
the Golden Gate Bridge where is the
Golden Gate Bridge well this weather
pattern may disappoint some many others
are now on a first-name basis with San
Francisco's fog Carla fog came out of
the fog from someplace this year and now
it's gone viral here when it comes to
views of the Golden Gate Bridge the fog
giveth and the fog taketh away and now
San Francisco's fog is on social media
it even has its own coffee table book on
Twitter Carl the fog has 360,000
followers this weather system also post
selfies on Instagram
proudly showing his impact on the city
and now Carl is a published author with
a book of his photos and his wisdom I am
NOT Carl the fog
I am Carl's editor Steve Marcus not only
edited Carl's book he's one of the few
people who actually knows the identity
of the human behind
he's really funny for a weather system
he's really funny if I may you put some
conditions on this interview Oh what was
the condition that we wouldn't talk
about Karl's identity I know you're
gonna ask me so we can go ahead and go
go for it I can't tell you anything you
work with real people in your job as a
book editor when that email arrived from
Karl when somebody told you okay you're
gonna be working with the fog next what
was that it was really exciting I mean I
so I was following his travails of their
social media and he really is a local
celebrity nothing could be more San
Francisco than hearing from Carla Fogg
you say people love the fog and people
hate the fog how do we know that Karl
isn't some part of a Russian
disinformation campaign aimed at
dividing us he's very kind
kind enough it turns out to pull back
that veil of white from time to time
providing a picture perfect setting as
long as you're quick and when the
picture isn't perfect
at least we can now blame Karl but who
is he really
sorry I haven't the foggiest for CBS
this morning Saturday John Blackstone
San Francisco John Blackstone I remember
my first trip to San Francisco and it
was in the summer right in July and
August yeah I can't I couldn't believe
it yeah hot 20 degrees hotter yeah yep
just over the next like 45 degrees and
raining yeah yeah at least Karl can take
really good pictures better than I can
fantastic for a fog